[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie so we got a
whole bunch of new Young Justice season
3 to talk about the creator's just
dropped a new promo I don't know if they
meant to but there was one on the
website the people found and then the
producers started posting it like you
know here's a new promo everybody enjoy
so everyone started freaking out but it
has had a couple of new characters that
we haven't seen before and it confirmed
some of the alternate costumes in the
previous promos that they released way
back at Comic Con but if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Young Justice videos
obviously it's not premiering till later
this year I'll talk a little bit more
about that at the end of the video
because there's been some more evidence
about when Titans is going to premiere
and Titans is supposed to precede Young
Justice season 3 as in Young Justice
season 3 won't premiere till after
Titans is done airing all its episodes
they also dropped a cyborg size bomb in
the Titans universe so what's happening
is is Doom Patrol is gonna be another
live-action TV series cyborg will
premiere on that TV show so we'll
probably have to do a separate video
about this later but if you ever
wondered about cyborg joining the Titans
on that DC streaming service it sounds
like he will because he's gonna be part
of the Doom Patrol show Doom Patrol is
gonna be a spin-off with Titans so just
open up a bookmark for that we'll talk
about that after Young Justice so left
to write characters on this new promo
here some of these are obviously new
katana Geoforce Metamorpho this red
character in the middle I'll talk about
him because there are a couple of
theories about who he is
katana you know who she is pretty
self-explanatory she's already been in
the live-action Suicide Squad movie
she's been all over the cartoons for a
while she's a member of The Outsiders in
the comic books Young Justice season 3
is subtitle is Young Justice outsiders
so naturally they have a huge big new
roster of characters a lot of those are
going to be characters from The
Outsiders comic books
there's geo force in the green costume
if you don't know who he is he is the
brother of Tara Markov his Breann Markov
like Baron Markov they briefly touched
on those characters Tara showed up
during the New Teen Titans Judas
contract storyline but obviously you
have to kind of treat that like it's in
a different universe Young Justice is
meant to be its own self-contained you
which is why there are certain rules for
the speedforce and how the speedsters
work so I'll also address that too
because they did say that they would be
doing some DC rebirth storyline and I
think that's more specific to the Wally
West character although you know a lot
of character redesigns and backstory
changes
read character in the middle two
possibilities for who he is he could be
a version of wild who's a good character
he's just a bear like he has claws you
can see he has four arms though bears
and the wild character in the comics do
not have four arms he could be a version
of Goliath just my two picks based on
how he looks so many websites and people
on Twitter were confused about this
woman in the yellow costume but I just
think it's an alternate costume design
like an upgrade for bumblebee because
based on black lightning and some of
these other characters in the background
like Nightwing we know that the
characters have multiple costume changes
so like you know Wally West had his
stealth costume that was an alternate
design during Young Justice season 1 & 2
the other characters which I'll explain
in a second also have alternate costume
changes
so there are a number of different
costume promos they released a comic-con
and people thought that they might be
different characters but they're really
just the same characters with alternate
costumes but obviously everybody knows
who Metamorpho is he was a member of The
Outsiders - there's Nightwing with a
slightly alternate costume there were
some people that thought that this
actually might be a different version of
Nightwing but no he just has a slight
costume change in a slight hairdo change
just remember that because of this big
upgrade for the series moving to the DC
streaming service they spent more money
more time redesigning the characters so
everybody's gonna get tweaked just a
little bit meaning costume upgrades
multiple costumes in slightly different
haircuts mostly to highlight the time
jump customary time jump just like there
was a time jump between seasons 1 & 2
based on the tigris character she said
she could benchmark when you compare
this look to her look at the end of
season 2 so I we seen the background
here you have Tigris you have black
lightning which is a much younger
version of the character if you've seen
the live-action black lightning TV show
and then Superboy a lot of people were
wondering where Superboy was in that
comic-con promo they released last year
because he didn't have his s on he was
in one of the stealth costumes but
Tigris in the
I'm John so look at her at the end of
season two they're still supposed to be
young justice relatively teenage
characters but older teenagers look at
her in this new promo from season three
does she not look like someone in her
mid-20s
like look at Superboy here too he also
looks like he's quite a bit older but
still very young I think this new time
jump is going to be closer to five years
because that's about how long it's been
in real life so think about how much the
characters have changed in the way that
they look the way they wear their hair
their costumes in a five-year period
that's why I think that they're doing
more adult storylines as they call you
know quote-unquote adult storylines what
does that mean this just means more
adult topics then say you would find in
something like Teen Titans or Teen
Titans go Teen Titans go
obviously the bane of most Teen Titans
fans but you can see how one skews
towards very young children and then
there are more adult cartoons like Rick
and Morty is probably a really good
example of an adult cartoon Young
Justice season 3 is supposed to be more
adult than Young Justice season 1 & 2
was but now going back to the comic-con
promo we can say that we know these are
now alternate costume designs stealth
costumes for these characters so left to
right there's Artemis in a slightly
different costume you have Nightwing
because of the Escrima sticks you have
Black Lightning because of the beard and
you have Superboy that just doesn't have
his S on the chest so you look at this
other big promo they released a
comic-con and you can see Artemis right
here on the right side is wearing a red
different costume it just means the
characters are gonna have multiple
costume changes during the season so
left to right some of these are actually
pretty obvious you have static you have
Bart Allen you have Tim Drake you have
cassie sandsmark Wonder Girl you have a
Stephanie Brown spoiler Blue Beetle very
obvious not much of a costume change for
him new character right next to him is
Tracy 13 she's a magic user she's
supposed to get a live-action TV show on
the CW next year at some point then
obviously you have Artemis you have Roy
Harper and Beast Boy so very clearly
these are not all the characters there's
still some missing people but because
they drop that new promo in the
creator's we're sharing it they'll
probably be dropping something more
pretty soon they said they just finished
recording all the
dialogue for all the episodes and there
will be 26 episodes total they didn't
say when the exact premiere date is
going to be but like I said there was a
rumor about when Titans was starting and
they were supposed to start after Titans
finished its run one of the actors from
Titans posted this said see you this
summer as in the episodes would be
dropping this summer so people are like
oh wow he very clearly went back and
changed that because somebody from the
network saw that and was like you
boiling when the premiere day is going
to be so when he's saying summer and
implying that they're going to premiere
during the summer that's probably the
end of the summer because one of the
writers for instance was up in Toronto
where they're shooting the TV series and
they're in this big warehouse saying
they're getting ready to shoot a scene
so they're still working on Titans it's
gonna be a while before they finish all
the episodes so earlier this year my
theory was is that they would try to
premiere an episode or at least part of
an episode at Comic Con than within a
couple weeks of comic-con start
premiering the actual episodes now
they're not confirming anything but if
this actors saying see you this summer
it just seems like that's kind of the
idea that they're going for but no
actual day confirmation like what is the
day we will actually be able to pay for
this DC streaming service or watch it
whatever their revenue model is going to
be and then obviously after those
episodes there will get some Young
Justice season 3 and I imagine they'll
just stretch that out to the Harley
Quinn show premieres and then we learned
about The Swamp Thing TV show and you
may have just seen that they announced
that the Doom Patrol is gonna get a
13-episode spin-off when they'd jpu on
Titans so it's all part of this Titans
DC streaming service universe but they
did quote that cyborg was going to show
up on the Doom Patrol TV series so a lot
of you when Titans was announced was
like what's the roster going to be is
cyborg got to be a member this just
seems like it's backdoor confirmation
that we will eventually see cyborg with
the Titans at some point even if he's
only a recurring character because he's
a little more expensive to do because of
the CG that's required so he exists
inside this Titans universe it just
seems like a matter of time before he
shows up on the Titans TV series but
obviously when these do drop I will do
videos for all the episodes so there'll
be a lot of reminders when we get to
comic-con
that's really what I'm expecting them to
reveal all this information like these
are all the details for how you will
watch these episodes
but what's happening later tonight is
the embargo is up on Deadpool too so I'm
allowed to post my non-spoilery review
you can click here for that I'll update
the link when I post that and you can
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]